pepa
de patín
spider-man
superman
the lion king sold a lot a lot a
lot
or ninja turtles
[Music]
we have been piñateros for 50 years
originally it was just us
now the whole town is practically
artisans dedicated to the same work
and started a  This family
later taught another family and
spread out in the technique
[Music]
in each piñata that you make you are
leaving a part of yourself as a person
because they are unique pieces
[Music]
there are also many people who value
work  and they resist and many don't break them
if they appreciate the art they appreciate the
character they appreciate their superhero and they don't
want to hit their superheroes
[Music]
if it's something complicated then if
you ask yourself why something so beautiful you
necessarily have to break it but
there sometimes there are things that if it really
hurts you that they go to the trash
because finally later you know what they
are designed for
you know that all this is going to be destroyed
[Music  a]
and you say good
[Music]
[Music] it
's nice to work on walls because
you work for children it sells that
joy to children
[Music
] I feel that this is something that is
beginning
as long as there are children in this world there
will always be party piñatas  and there's going
to be fun
[Music]